اعلن الرئيس بايدن الاسبوع الماضي ان
الولايات المتحده ستدعم جهود الحلفاء
المشتركه لتدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على
طائرات الجيل الرابع بما فيها طائرات اف
16 نامل ان تبدا التدريبات في الاسابيع
المقبله
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم في انجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم موسكو تقول انها احبطت
محاوله دبرتها المخابرات الاوكرانيه
لتخريب محطتين نوويتين روسيتين وتوقع
اتفاقا مع بيلاروسيا لنشر صواريخ نوويه
تكتيكيه وكيف تؤكد ان عمليه الهجوم المضاد
يجري تنفيذها بالفعل ضد القوات الروسيه
بينما صرح وزير الدفاع الامريكي بان تدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على مقاتله اف 16
سيبدا قريبا بعد تاكيد المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه للجزيره ان بلاده لا
تزال تؤمن بالتوصل الى حل دبلوماسي بشان
ملف ايران النووي طهران تقول ان تقدما
جيدا احرز بشان المفاوضات وتميت اللثام عن
صاروخ باليستين جديد في خضم التوتر مع
اسرائيل وجيشه الاحتلال يقول ان تهديدات
كبار قادته لا تعني انه بصدد حرب على
لبنان او على طهران قريبا
الناخبون الاتراك في الخارج يسجلون رقما
قياسيا في الاقبال على التصويت في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه مقارنه
بالجوله الاولى حيث صوت فيها نحو مليون
وتسعمائه الف ناخب في الممثليات الخارجيه
والمعابر الحدوديه
المانيا تدخل رسميا في حاله ركود اقتصادي
لاول مره منذ ذروه جائحه كورونا وللمره
الثانيه خلال 30 سنوات بعدما سجل الاقتصاد
الالماني كماشا في معدل نمو للربع الثاني
على التوالي مع تراجع انفاق الاسر
والمستهلكين ابرز محرك لعجله النمو في
اكبر اقتصاد او ربعي الى اللقاء